[Music]
okay action in what Hollywood I will do
action we do hora and we do African
witchcraft
we're always improvising here whatever
we feel like we want with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a liga a slummin Uganda's capital
of Kampala is home to a burgeoning low
budget DIY cinema industry called what
Hollywood think action-packed comedies
with shootouts car chases explosions
zombies all with a shoestring budget
Hollywood is a name that comes from the
word waka Liga where I grew up and where
I am right now and would from the
Hollywood because all movies we knew
we're from Hollywood how's that okay
action
my name is Isaac an iguana good for your
friend the founder of war Hollywood and
the dielectric here I do editing I do
camera and shooting action and I write
action movies I started making movies in
2005 but the dream was back in 1986
around that when I was a teenager today
Isaac has made over 40 movies most for
nothing more than $200 he is what Kali
was only director for now but people
from all over have come to support what
Hollywood in all kinds of ways my name
was Alan Hoffman is my name now in
Uganda is Allen Sally Oh Ian Chima
massager walk Ibaka and I'm FMEA Selig
on the laptop Hoffman
[Music]
so if you enjoy Mozingo getting beaten
wait till you see Mizzou who getting
beaten his actors aren't paid and most
have side jobs ranging from teachers
nurses and lawyers I trained my own I
believe that everyone can be a star I
get them from all over the country we
will come everyone because we feel like
you know movies the funding the props
Department is like a workshop we'll make
everything we want which we cannot buy
we can do our own lights we can do our
own jib we can do our own dories and
everything what the guns there's so many
you know things we need it and we cannot
buy by improvising we make them in his
watch of their or very good at you know
using the little I have his first film
who killed captain Alex brought
widespread attention to Hollywood after
uploading it to YouTube it quickly went
viral and gained a cult following
worldwide I knew no one had ever done an
action movie in Africa so I knew if it
goes out people will be at least give it
you know a chance everyone loved it and
the captain Alex became a hit what
started as a dream that was borderline
fantasy has turned into a full-fledged
production house that has gone
mainstream I did not go to school to
learn movies I don't know you know
festivals I don't know our works when I
make movies my main goal is for the
people to enjoy when we watch them they
love it because it is fun it's it was
comedy it was everything so I feel like
life without you know laughing laugh
without comment this is not life
you
[Music]